burland liftin back with little to write
home about tourists generally don't come
to this part of town this traditional
home turf or the left has just been
shaken by the arrival of the right-wing
populist party alternative for Germany
coming from nothing the AFD took almost
a fifth of the vote yet nobody is
surprised as expected what's real wat it
was to be expected many people are
dissatisfied and that's why they vote
for parties unpopular with the
establishment class session folks
pattern gets Lisa getting dizzy invent
Caston vol died is the number two on the
regional list clearly the AFD has high
hopes for the man who found a new
political home with them after leaving
Angela Merkel CDU he left because he
felt he could no longer recognize his
conservatives under Merkel's leadership
criticism still heard in the CDU the
Berlin result she insists are more than
protest that's until the hope voters
we've seen the established parties
present their policies as the only
option the voters no longer wanted to be
presented with a policy that offers no
alternative so they voted 4-1 the Left
Party managed to defend its alishan back
lead against some predictions Hendrika
Klein came top of her constituency race
she admits that the AFD is currently
hard to beat the name doing sevierville
they take the fears of the people and
heighten them further it's quite simple
really some hope that the AFD will
disappear again within the next two or
three years I don't think that will
happen the shift to the right is not a
purely German phenomenon right Espino
mean polls show that Germans are
currently worried by a sense of loss of
political control a sentiment that was
heightened by Angela Merkel's open doors
policy on migration